[Música]
en nuestra Crónica de salud nos acompaña
más Romero salamar bienvenida cómo está
Muy bien gracias comenzamos entonces
este lunes con la noticia del día y es
que la OMS sigue considerando el Coby 19
como una emergencia sanitaria
internacional Qué significa esto Pues
así es Es una reunión del comité de
emergencia del cómic que se hizo el
viernes recordemos que llevan tres años
reuniéndose cada tres meses para
revaluar esta situación todo el mundo
pensaba que quizás esta era en la que
iban a levantar este estatus de
emergencia pero no fue así sus
argumentos básicamente es pues que la
situación todavía entraña mucho riesgo
hay un número muy alto de muertes en
comparación con otras enfermedades
respiratorias infecciosas que falta
vacunación en grupos de riesgo y en
países de ingresos bajos y medios y que
Todavía existe una posibilidad de que
emerjan variantes recordemos que cada
contagio Es una posibilidad para que el
virus mute entonces Cuantos más
contagios más riesgo de posibles
variantes emergentes vamos a las cifras
sobre las que se sos este comité de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud vemos
que hubo en diciembre y luego un poco
más tarde a principios de enero un pico
de contagios y de muertes relacionado
con la reapertura de China que pues
cubrimos ampliamente aquí y que en
cambio ahora A mediados de enero estamos
en unos 2,4 millones de contagios
semanales y han habido 23.000 muertes
también semanales son cifras que están
por supuesto lejos de los picos que
vimos en 2020 o 2021 como micron pero
que no dejan de ser mucho más altos Pues
que muchas otras enfermedades que se le
pueden comparar Eso quiere decir que
después de más de dos años todavía no
podemos decir que la pandemia se ha
acabado más de dos años es optimista ya
son casi tres años desde que se declaró
para que para que lo tengamos claro y
bueno sigue siendo muy difícil llegar a
una conclusión no a pesar de decir por
ejemplo que mantienen este nivel de
alarma Es verdad que por primera vez
este comité reconocía que estamos cerca
de un punto de inflexión no
podemos estarnos acercando al momento en
que estas variables epidemiológicas
cambian pero que el virus se quedará
circulando entre nosotros en el futuro
cercano aquí lo vemos esta frase no
conseguir niveles más altos de inmunidad
a través de la infección y de la
vacunación podría limitar el impacto
pero que el virus se quedará circulando
el comité recomienda precisamente la OMS
empezar a buscar medidas de transición
por ejemplo el estatus de emergencia
hace que legalmente haya patentes que no
se están aplicando que haya vacunas que
están aprobadas amparándose en este
estatus entonces legalmente va a tener
que haber una transición sí o no Y para
cerrar este tema también recordar que no
es raro que una pandemia al final tenga
varios fines no Un fin legal muchos
países ya levantaron hace tiempo sus
estados de emergencia internacionalmente
todavía vemos que se va a mantener un
fin social que tiene que ver con la
percepción de riesgo que yo creo que
muchos ya hemos cruzado digamos del otro
lado y un cine epidemiológico que tendrá
que ver cuando el virus sea predecible
no lo sabremos probablemente hasta que
hayamos pasado ya los primeros ciclos
como decíamos de virus predecible y No
necesariamente es algo que celebrar
significa que quizás pueden averiguar
millones de muertes anualmente bueno y
otra enfermedad que tampoco termina y
que lleva incluso muchísimos más años
que el Coby 19 es la lepra Y ayer
domingo se celebró se conmemoró el día
mundial contra la lepra sí como decías
es una de las enfermedades más antiguas
de las que se tienen registros y eso a
veces nos hace tener la percepción de
que es una enfermedad que quedó en el
pasado Pero no es así en nuestro
continente Brasil es el segundo país del
mundo con más casos de lepra también
conocida como enfermedad de hansen 155
mil casos entre 2016 y 2020 nuestra
corresponsal Valeria sacona nos envió
este informe
hace siete meses este hombre de 51 años
descubrió que padece una enfermedad que
todavía genera discriminación
yo estaba en casa y cuando me levanté mi
cuerpo estaba lleno de pequeñas manchas
no sabía lo que era fui al médico y
pensó que era viruela del mono
sin embargo el diagnóstico fue
inesperado enfermedad de hansen
popularmente conocida como lepra yo no
tuve miedo el problema principal es
contárselo a las personas no todo el
mundo sabe lo que es la enfermedad de
hansen hay mucho prejuicio Hoy es un día
importante porque Fernando va a empezar
su tratamiento en la fundación Osvaldo
cruz de Río de Janeiro es todo más
referencia en la investigación
científica en Brasil
cuando empiece a tomar el remedio la
única cosa que le pasa a todo el mundo
es que su orina se va a quedar muy roja
a pesar de ser el segundo país del mundo
con más casos según la Organización
Mundial de la Salud todavía hay mucha
desinformación
lo que importa para la enfermedad de
hansen es hacer un diagnóstico precoz y
un tratamiento precoz sólo así vamos a
poder evitar la incapacidad la
deformidad y el estigma la enfermedad de
hansen no es tan contagiosa como se
piensa se contrae por las vías
respiratorias pero solo tras una
convivencia prolongada con algún enfermo
no va a haber problemas porque sabemos
que esta enfermedad tiene tratamiento
vas a quedar bien solo tienes que
medicarte correctamente Fernando no va a
tener que pagar nada por la atención
médica ni por los medicamentos el
sistema Público de salud cubre todos los
gastos
es un año de tratamiento y se cura al
100% Durante un año una vez por mes
vendré aquí para hacer las revisiones
para ver cómo estoy
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
espera erradicar esta enfermedad en 2030
hasta Entonces Fernando Espera que para
él sea tan solo un recuerdo
y Ojalá llegue el momento en el que no
sea solo un recuerdo para este paciente
sino para toda la humanidad Gracias mar
por esta sección de salud Muchas gracias
María Clara